north Korea has returned the possible
remains of 55 American troops killed
during the Korean War a US military
transport plane carrying the remains
landed overnight at an air base in South
Korea dozens of US service members
greeted the plane on its arrival last
night President Trump tweeted after so
many years this will be a great moment
for so many families thank you to Kim
jong-un David Martin is at the Pentagon
this morning David good morning good
morning this would be the first time in
more than a decade remains of American
servicemen have been returned from North
Korea and it comes sixty-five years to
the day after the end of combat in the
Korean War
one by one u.s. soldiers carried the
fifty five sets of remains off the c-17
in front of a military honor guard their
fellow servicemen watching over the
fallen as they passed by in wooden
caskets straped in United Nations flags
these are believed to be the remains of
some of the 5,300 servicemembers last
known to be in North Korea it absolutely
should not and must not be considered a
trade retired Admiral James Winnefeld
says North Korea sees this act as a tool
to make headway in negotiations with the
United States it's clear that if the
North Koreans are doing this as a
goodwill measure that they are serious
because they would not give up a
bargaining chip as they view it not as
we should view it if they didn't think
there was the potential for progress
they call it the wound that never heals
Rick downs was three years old when his
father Hao left to serve in the Korean
War his Air Force bomber went down over
North Korea in 1952 the pilot and
navigator ejected and survived what did
they tell you about what they thought
had happened to your father they had no
idea was either of them able to witness
the crash the navigator said the plane
went down over finally crashed over a
hill and he heard the ammunition going
off that's all that's all we know now he
is becoming more hopeful this time with
a promise by Kim jong-un the President
Trump during their June summit to return
remain
from the war you have to really watch
your heart here because this all could
just fizzle this could be nothing it
could be everything the remains will now
undergo preliminary testing in South
Korea next week they will be flown to
Hawaii where they will be back on
American soil
after 65 years and where forensic
scientists will attempt to identify the
remains and return them to their
families Noora very important for those
families David thank you